think for me other pair of numbers pair
of numbers and we want to add to
negative 18 we want to multiply to 45 do
you have the pair number minus 15 minus
3 so these are pretty big numbers
there's my minus 15 and my minus three
okay what next yeah
okay now your knife was with that yeah
that's right you're doing this part you
doing this part and often by the way
you've got a lot of different candidates
that work here right so we already went
2 minus 3 minus 15 minus 9 minus 9
checks out here minus 3 my no hold on no
yeah that one's ok - 3 and - I already
did - we - we think well I think you
minus 6 and minus 12 works here right
you could have a lot of different
options here but you have to check out
that they work here also generally
speaking this is a better way to go to
look at because it has fewer factors
that this has pairs that L up - ok I
factorized I expanded and I factorize
because at different points expanding
was more useful and other points
factorizing was more useful what's the
point what am I trying to get to
three or fifteen okay
so just before I will come to you in a
second this is usually where we end
isn't it
right you're like I had a quadratic they
even told me to write a quadratic like
write a suitable form and solve a
suitable quadratic and then I have two
answers which is usually where I end
okay are we happy with this
what was your were you gonna suggest
something or ask a question wait which
lady talking about line one two three
four or five this line you are you
looking at these terms here yeah yeah
this one here one here and then it's
centrist one is that okay yep good okay
so hold on I had a few of you saying
yeah I'm a bit iffy about this solution
but I like I like my two answers what's
what's gone wrong yeah oh you had a
question yeah yeah that's a really good
question I don't know why your I'd love
your opinion on this missus least I'd
sort of teated between it sort of more
go towards yet between two and three
between two and three when you have a
look at how much has gone into this I
could easily find three spots that I
could say oh there's a distinct skill
here that I'm looking for a student to
demonstrate right but at the same time
this is assumed knowledge right
Pythagoras you know quadratics you know
I know it took a long time to get there
that's partly because I was talking you
through it and we're looking at
different options all that kind of thing
okay so it kind of depends yeah there
are no straight answers sorry about that
if there was an answer any games that we
then needed to eliminate which enhances
the situation yeah
as we're about to shortly demonstrate
did you have another question you would
ask okay you go ahead okay so I've got
this x equals 3 or 15 right now we've
seen in algebra we can check both of
these solutions against what we started
off with and in this case this is the
very first time an equation appears
right now I'm going to go right out on a
limb and I'm gonna say if you test
either then you have a calculator you're
welcome to test it right I'm pretty sure
they'll both work pretty sure they'll
both work and go ahead if you're like
you there's enough of you at a table
someone test three chuck it into here
someone test fifteen chuck it in say
what happens I'll even do it right now
let's see here
if I put in 15 that's 225 plus 64 which
I'm pretty sure is 289 which is 17
squared right and you do it with you can
do it three right then what's that
nine plus negative four squared that's
going to be 16 amperes 16 is 25 which is
five squid so they both check out with
the equation right but the equation is
not the very first thing that I put on
the board
do you remember there's something else
literally above the equation that I did
first what was it it was is this picture
right now I flagged this earlier I said
oh we drew a picture and then we wrote
out this equation and then kind of our
algebra brain sort of you know kicked
into gear and we kind of temporarily
forgot that this was a shape right but
it is still a shape this X is supposed
to be something up here now if someone
already noticed that one of these
solutions 3 or 15 one of them has a big
glaring problem with it when you try and
look back at the original shape which
one has a problem 3 is a problem right
why does that Rama
yeah yeah you get a three here and then
you get a five here and then you like oh
my triangle has a negative four
centimeter long side what's up with that
right so we need to exclude one of these
answers okay now what I just said you
probably don't want to write ooh there's
a negative what you don't want to write
that okay you can say but right and this
is in fact I'm gonna do it over here
because I think it's gonna require a
little bit of space I'm gonna say but
you have these things which imply
restrictions on your values they can't
just be anything you like their lengths
so every single length has to be
positive including this one right X
minus seven is a length right so
therefore X minus seven the value it has
to be isn't allowed to be equal to zero
can I can I let it be exactly zero no I
can't because then there's no triangle
is there so it has to be greater than
and not equal to zero right that thing
has to be positive that means that X is
greater than seventy you can see why x
equals three no longer satisfies that
right so therefore x equals 15 oh really
all right so that's kind of sneaky right
because they didn't sort of you know
you're you brain kicks into this mode
and then you forget the kind of question
you're actually looking at a really
really common error for students to me